over a larger sample size of games
hikaru should be favored
right now we've got one of these funny
gambits
uh black wins the e4 pawn but white has
the initiative
and uh these positions can get super
wild the queen comes out to the king
side
if castles was played there the move
queen h5 or bbc takes h7
danny just called it a funny gambit
white just
but blundered the central pawn critical
to the entire seen this before
i've seen this before no it wasn't this
guy
i just i just i was enjoying that i was
just enjoying that
i thought it was i thought it was
something i've seen before what
he just pre-moved and lost his central
pawn danny's like yes this is a great
gambit
a lot of play for white